I'm a little upset today you know what
I'm actually a lot upset today I'm upset
with the little man the little man is
the person in your life who cast doubt
on everything you're doing who tells you
that you're not good enough who tells
you that you can't make it who tells you
that it's not possible that whatever you
have in mind your business dream you
can't do that
that's the little man that's how the
little man thinks there's a little man
in my life right now who is casting all
sorts of doubt over what I'm doing and
says what I'm doing is not gonna work
and now I'm at the point now in my
career where I don't care I don't care
what little man says I'm gonna keep
going because I know what's gonna work
why am I upset is that little man exists
because little man is a dream killer we
all have a little man in our lives and
if you listen to them they will kill
your dream that's why I'm upset
you think about it okay dreams are
really fragile things when did you come
up with your idea for your business for
a lot of people you know you might be
lying in bed and and you can't sleep
because you've got this great idea and
for one moment for one moment you have
the courage to say to yourself I can do
this I can be better than I am right now
I can build something great I'm gonna
challenge myself to do something better
you have that moment of courage and
excitement and boldness and that takes a
lot of energy to do and so you're going
and what do you do you tell your friends
and you tell the people in your circle
about your idea and your friends your
true friends are gonna be the people who
support you they're gonna be the people
who tell you that's a great idea do you
think the people who find the holes in
your plan and help you fix them because
here's a newsflash you're not gonna have
all the answers you don't have it all
figured out this is just an idea right
now
and that's okay you don't have to have
it all figured out from the beginning
your friends will help you get through
that the little man the little man he's
the guy who's gonna look at all the
holes in your plan and tell you why it's
not gonna work well that's not gonna
work and that's not gonna work and this
isn't gonna work and cast doubt I make
you feel like you're not good enough
like you can't achieve this and the
challenge here is because it's so early
stage because this is just a dream for
you right now little man's doubt makes
you doubt yourself and that one moment
of courage that you had to think of
yourself as somebody who could go do
something great that moment of courage
you have is eliminated and bam little
man smashes you back down to an average
life even if little man has no idea what
he's talking about has no experience has
never done this before doesn't know what
he's talking about his doubt makes you
doubt yourself and kills your dream
that's why I'm upset with little man you
need to believe in yourself in your
abilities in your values and what you
stand for more than you believe in
little man because his opinions don't
count you could build something great if
you believe in yourself believe for
those you're watching like the video
give it a thumbs up below leave a
comment let me know what you think tell
me if you're on board with me tell me if
you hate the little man - this has been
a great experience getting this off my
chest so thank you and if you like the
channel you want to see more videos you
can subscribe click on my face there
thank you so much and I'll see you soon